[Music]
so hello everybody welcome to this
lecture grandmaster choice my name is
pat the koenkan and i'm very glad to be
here with all of you and today we're
gonna see a game that i played recently
in the ibero-american championship in
this tournament people from South
America Central America and Spain and
Portugal compete it was a really
important moment because we are in round
number 7 and then I'm facing Jorge
quarry we who was number one in this
tournament he is almost 2700 so we were
in board number 2 so I had a great
opportunity to score and then to stay in
the lead and anybody of you knows Jorge
quarry sorry
he was here okay yeah so he is really
talented so he young his sister desi
Cody she is the number one of the row he
is the number one of the roof he was
actually studying in the states I think
with one of these good scholarships yeah
the game is extremely complex so let's
take a look at that so I had the white
pieces and I wanted to play I wanted to
play aggressively so I decided to go for
a 4 and then Jorge replied with a 6 so
this is their the French defense exactly
so d4 d5 and Knight c3 as you guys know
there are many possibilities here
so they advance variation 92 you know
how this is called the tirage exactly or
Bishop d3 this is a funny move but it's
very interesting for I recorded a video
series about this move Bishop d3 and
it's very tricky and then you can
surprise a lot your opponents
so next III I decided to go and hear
that three main options let's say so D
takes e4 Knight f6 going for the
classical French or Bishop before and
this is one of the most complicated
openings do you know how this is called
after Bishop before you said yeah that
we know where yeah and it's extremely
complicated because after a 5 C 583
normally black takes on c3 B takes c3
and the structure is very very difficult
to understand so White has doubled pawns
from the C file and then if you don't
manage to play dynamically then in most
of n games you could suffer here on the
C file so after Knight c3 hork I decided
to go for NAR f6 and here again two main
options or three so Bishop g5 is one of
them E 5 and also it takes d5 it takes
d5 is not really aggressive so I decided
to go for a 5-4 seen black snag to go to
d7 and then what will you play here with
the white pieces yes
f4y yeah that's my lab but there is a
reason behind right because black wants
to break with c5 and then these pawns
this pawn chain could be really unstable
mostly the pawn on e5 right so let's say
you play something like Bishop e2 then
after c5 you could be already in trouble
because if you take on c5 then this pawn
is hanging on e5 this central pawn and
the central pawns are really important
this will mostly fall as well so that's
why you have to reinforce the pawn chain
in the center that's why everybody plays
here f4 so see 593 thou now there's no
trouble with this if I point right yeah
sure Bishop c4 Bishop f4 you mean
yeah Bishop f4 is natural move but then
after c5 again this point is gonna
suffer a lot there's gonna be a lot of
pressure for example with 96 and then
Black has some ideas even with g5 and
then attacking this Bishop but then it's
better just to protect this point with
f4 because now this pawn is gonna be
anyway under attack after knight c6
right so that's why f4 is really really
important in this position you can also
play Knight c2e2 this is another move
and after c5 you play c3 but anyway you
will have to go f4 in in the next in the
next move
so f4 yes please don't hesitate to ask
if you have any questions you see this
way will be more fun okay so c5 Knight
f3 knight c6 and Bishop e3 protecting in
d4 and now there are many many
possibilities here for black so Queen b6
is a direct attempt attacking b2 it's
one of them a six in order to go b5 is
another option for black as I said Queen
b6 also see texted for followed by
Bishop c5 but then Jorge decide to go
for Bishop e7 I really natural move
develop in you want to go sure castle in
the next move right
I went for Queen d2 and now short castle
and one question for you guys what would
you play here with white yes
we should be - it's a decent move
short-long castle it's a natural move
but it's a bad move and I already
suffered one loss after this long castle
I didn't know the theory the time I was
in the Portuguese league like back in
2007 or something like that 12 years ago
I was an I am that type and I was facing
a Mattel's bar - he said 2600 player
from Poland he is really strong and then
I didn't know that this was a bad move
you know the reason why is this so bad
c4 exactly
now black closes deposition and then b5
is coming straight away you take this
point and be fine later there you're
gonna suffer the consequences so long
Castle is not a very good idea that's
why if you want to go long castle you
have to do something in advance so if
you want to go long castle exactly take
the pawn first D takes e5 and then up in
the next move then long castle is
possible there are two ways of
recapturing this with blood pieces now
you can take with the base shop you can
take with a knight even native sorry
Queen a five is an interesting move but
ok he decided to take with the night
Jorge and then I went long castle in
this position and these positions are
extremely fun to play because Kings and
on opposite flank right so white is
gonna try to start an attack on the
Kings side and then black is going to do
the same on the Queen side by playing a
6 b5 using the C file later because
there is an open file semi up and file
over there so that's why Corki goes for
a 6 I'm here I tried to follow sorry I
tried to follow an idea from one of your
compatriots Shang Shanklin in one of
these games he went 8 4 and this is what
I repeated here the idea is rather
simple you want to go in some positions
you want to push this pawn to h5 and h6
there are some other lines where you are
aiming to go Bishop d3 and then this
sacrifice on 87 you know how this
sacrifice on 87
it's called exactly the Greek gift so
basically you want to take on eight
seven and then go Knight g5 right so
Harkey went for b5 and then I went for
Bishop d3 and one of the thing is that
actually hurt had played the same
position two weeks before this game
against Peter Lego you know Peter let go
it's a really strong super Grand Master
from Hungary and in that game her head
took on d3 and this is what I had
prepared for the game night X III
quintet c3 and then Queen before you got
a play here we night before sorry
because otherwise White's plain Knight
g5 and then you're forcing black to play
t6 and then you can break with h5 and
then that looks terrible for black right
so that gained against like Oh continued
in the following game night before Queen
d2 Bishop e7 Kim b1 rook c8 f5 and then
this was a real mess actually
Corki ended up losing this gain against
Peter Lego in BL in July this year to
2019 but instead Corki played extremely
fast in less than 10 seconds went for
this move Knight B 4 and then I was
thinking you know I didn't prepare for
this line so I was checking like two
three options from the the engine and
none of them were night before but this
has to be his preparation right because
he played this same game against Peter
legong he lost that game so I thought
okay he must have prepared this line
with black right
but no it was a bluff so actually it's a
losing move but you know how important
is psychology in chess like I was so
scared because I mean I knew that bish
of 87 had to be a strong move but I
couldn't believe that Jorge didn't
prepare for this game
I mean after having played this same
position to which before al
using against peter alaikum so what do
you think about Bishop 87 of course I
was calculating here for 40 minutes 40
minutes 40 minutes yet until here I was
in my preparation of course but here I
had to think do I sacrifice on 87 I mean
I have all my pieces perfectly placed
for this great gift I can take on 87 and
then playing 95 but is that winning or
not let's see if you guys can calculate
the same things I calculated in my game
at the end I didn't play Bishop 87 I
went for Kim b1 a solid booth yeah Kim
b1 is the other option right but so what
do we do do we take 187 and if we take
white and where are the lines behind so
can you calculate something let's
calculate together so sorry so tell me
yes yeah
yes okay so this is one of the lines I
saw in the game so Bishop eight seven
King takes 95 King g8 of course taking
where the bishop is just a suicide right
so let's say here and then you have many
moves for example Queen e2 even g4
should be waiting for Queen h2 but okay
King G is a most natural move and then
you would like to go Queen d3 right at
this point but then there are two nights
here so you said okay I'm gonna remove
this guy and then play a three and then
how about 96 Queen d3 this is the line
that I saw on g6 and now what do we play
h5 and then I was checking this line in
the game 95 Queen 83 okay what did I see
here I I was thinking about King g7 and
then if you take on j6 then grew
ka-ching looks like black is holding
right hard to believe but and a piece
down so we have to find something
concrete otherwise 94 which night night
see to e4 okay I'll just go with Ruby 7
and then
it smells good for white but if you
don't see anything concrete would you go
for that if you don't see checkmate but
this actually one language is much much
better for white yeah then then is that
genocide yeah okay the line is the
following one
so King T eight and now there is a
better move can you find it instead of a
three Bishop takes e5 a three a more
direct approach against black skin yes
perfect now you saw the move Queen e2
and then of course white thread is
rather simple you want to go Queen h5
and checkmate so the only move is g6 and
now 85 and then I also checked this line
during the game but to be honest I was
99% of the time calculating Bishop c5
and a3 as you did here but this line is
completely winning for white because
your plan is extremely simple now and
black has to pay attention to this night
on c5 that now is hanging because it had
to take on on g5 basically let's say if
you play something like Queen c7 how do
we win takes takes enough Koen g4 is
interesting but this plan is very very
simple and effective and just wins the
game so I had a really good chance
round number seven out of nine I'm
facing number one of the tournament
board two and then the guy just blunders
Bishop eight seven
no I think he thought he that's one Lang
he prepared some months ago so he
thought he could play this but then
probably he realized that Bishop 87 was
winning as well but I didn't go for
Bishop 87 and then you know how I felt
like and there were Spanish broadcast
and there were people following me and
then I you start to think okay now if I
don't play Bishop 87 they will say come
on these guys it's too bad it's not
brave enough so should I go for visual
eight seven even if doesn't work but if
I go for Bishop 87 and then it doesn't
work they will think I'm stupid so so
finally I didn't go for this and I went
team b1 right I lost my chance to get a
winning position in move number 13
against a 2700 okay but the game
continues yeah and you're gonna see that
the game becomes extremely complex so he
goes for Knight xb3
now he realizes the danger of this
Bishop and then see take C 3 and B 4 how
would you play now with the white pieces
you'll go 92 or is there any other
option here for you there are two
options basically here - only two moves
where you don't blunder something
exactly that's a that's a really
interesting approach taking on c5 I went
for 92 because I thought okay let's see
who arrives first I thought 92 then I'm
gonna put this knight on d4 and then I'm
gonna start a pawn storm on the keen
side with g4 f5 and then of course it's
gonna try to do something on the Queen
side with a5 a4 even b3 but this
approach was extremely interesting - we
should take c5 we should take c5 and now
92 no you go 94 exactly 94 and now play
d4 this was the other option which was
very interesting because you got the C
file then you can put a knight on c5 and
then you are not giving up on the Kin
side you can still play d4 f5 ideas h5
five etcetera etcetera but okay I
finally decided to go for 92 so black
develops finally this Bishop to d7 and
then I went G for rook c8 from Corki and
I played Nike to D for this square was
sorry
sorry guys this D square is extremely
tasty for this knife right you are
aiming to go f5 in the next move
so basically black has to do something
quickly otherwise this attack is gonna
be extremely stone it's from sorry after
f5 there are many f6 ideas trying to
open open up to blow up in the position
here so that's why curcuit right
b3 a nice another important moment do I
take the pawn on b3 do i close with a 3
what would you do
you got five seconds in the club sorry a
three I think that's a little bit better
than what I did because I just took this
pawn I was so hungry but a three is
actually pretty interesting there many
possibilities for black here black could
go Bishop b5 attack in d3 and then if
you take on b5 then there's these before
break also there are many sacrificing
ideas 9a four followed by Knight B 2 and
then a 3 will hunt but anyway I decided
to take with Knight xp3 night XV 398 we
three-point XV 3 and a 5 and now you are
see you see [ __ ] has idea you just want
to play a 4 and then open these 2 lines
and it looks extremely extremely
dangerous from me so I needed to hurry
up as well and I decided to go for a
pawn sacrifice here f5 which her kid
didn't except he was scared and he went
for Bishop f4 let's try to see what
happens if I if her head takes on a 5
when we analyzed the game later he said
he was afraid of 94 Bishop g4 root G 1
h5 and rook takes g4 followed by 85 and
then he thought he this was much better
for white it is not the engine says
black is much better but it looks scary
right I was thinking about all the moves
too after it takes GTX Bishop takes f5 I
was thinking about Queen G 2 for example
in order to stop Bishop g4 and then try
to push with h5 also h5 straightaway was
really interesting so what I mean is
there are many many attacking ideas here
for both sides so anything could happen
but instead after f5 he decided to go
for Bishop f4 attack him the Queen and I
went for Queen f2 I think this was the
best player because I'm supporting the
f5 point I am also in many many
positions aiming to go Bishop e6 so
forcing this screen to go to a more
passive square like a 7 or 8 and he went
for Queen c7 if he goes a 4 I think
black white could just go Bishop e6
Queen d7 and now FC
these ideas are very very dangerous for
black let's say black takes and for
example Queen d4 you take Knight takes
e4 you are aiming to go g5 Knight g4
negative six checkmate and it's not easy
to create contemplate for black here so
that's why he went Queen c7 now Bishop
b6 doesn't make any sense and f6 we're
almost there so now another important
moment for black it black goes with g6
there will be a lot of attacking areas
with Queen eight six at some point also
8 5 trying to open up this h-file so
that's why her key wanted to hurry up as
well you see this is like a horse race
both running like beasts in every flank
and see who is arriving first so a4 what
do we play here
ruk ruk c1 is an interesting move any
other option I mean what's the most
natural move here 94 and check the porn
right we take the part attacking the
root and then if white sorry black takes
on g7 it's gonna be extremely exposed
right so that's why after 8 x g7
Hercules decided to play rook F to e 8
so maybe he thinks this skin is a little
bit more safer he doesn't take the pawn
on g7 and of course could be but then
they're also different attacking ideas
so how do we play now with the white
pieces the most direct approach 95 right
attack f7 and hurricane when four rook
is seven if black takes if black plays
Bishop b5 to protect the pawn with the
Queen then we could just take the pawn
rook c1 deviation the Queen has to
protect f7 let's say Queen b7 and now
there is a brilliant move here go for it
exactly Queen f6 exactly this is really
strong night at 7:00 and if black takes
then Queen f6 followed by Queen 86 and
Queen h8 checkmate
so that's why working after 95 he had to
protect that pump with Rukia 7 and then
now it's not that simple night 87
why because sorry where did they go
sorry we are here Ruki 7 now if you take
on 87 then black can just play 8 XV 3
yes when here Queen f6 here I think I'm
gonna make you in two Moops with Queen
c2 King a 1 and a 2 X B 3 and then there
is Rukh a a checkmate you see now black
is also very very fast in this position
so we gotta be careful yeah this is what
I played actually in the game I went for
Roxy once so there are no more Quincy to
ideas and if I take on 87 then 80 X B 3
and then Blackie is threatening the same
stuff Queen c2 so that's why after
rookie 7 I went rook c1 attacking the
Queen so quick a5 was played and then I
decided to trade Brooks so one less rook
and he takes a 4 and I thought ok I
think I'm doing fine because he's still
far away from checkmate in me and then
my plan is rather simple as you say
Queen f6 Queen 8 6 Queen 87 also this
narrates 7 ideas so for example if white
is sorry black takes on a 4 then 9 8 7
Kim takes 8 7 Queen f6 just wins and if
he goes for ruk a 7 then 9 of 6 King g7
exactly
so black can take because there is me
right he goes to h8
57 I just take it right night in that
age five I'm thinking of fate then we're
running out of moves
so route k7 check Bishop 8 6 y Bishop 8
6 why you don't take the rookin I said
right there is Bishop 8 7 so that's why
Roque 7 was not even possible
so if black goes Bishop a6 here then the
land you were suggested so Bishop 8 6 if
King h8 you can just play Queen c2 and
then white is too many points out but
okay Jorge says you know what I'm not
going to take on a four I'm gonna play
prophylactically against your nine eight
seven or Queen f6 let's see if you see
the same move as Jorge played in the
game so how do we stop night at seven or
Queen f6
sorry eight-six I'm not so sure you
stopping that because you can still go
tonight at 7:00 right and there's no
difference actually no an active moon
sorry Queen 86 that's an idea but even
better visual eight-six this Bishop is
really passive here so Bishop eight-six
was a really strong move from hooker
because now if Knight x7 just Bishop d3
and then you can always take this night
if Queen f6 there is Bishop d3 and this
game is gonna get checkmated so I went
Queen c2 here protecting everything
protecting a4 and d3 and what am i
threatening now with the white pieces d4
that's a really huge threat you wanna
play d4 and then Queen 887 checkmate and
at this point we we both had like 1
minute in the clock you see we in this
championship you play with 90 minutes
plus 30 seconds for every month so we
wearing real time trouble really because
the position and the game has been
extremely complex right and then so
we're running out of time so okay place
d4 I moved that I didn't see and then I
have 40 seconds in the clock what would
you do with 40 seconds you got 37
already you take it yeah and then we
lose the game
how
let's see you guys find out the solution
exactly Queen d5 double attack simple
this and this and we have to resign so
that's why I couldn't take it and at
this point there was a really beautiful
move then I couldn't find I mean I went
Bishop f4 so just trying to keep my
options there so not blundering anything
but there is a really beautiful move
that wins the game for white here I
couldn't believe it when I saw it later
of course I think we didn't see this not
him not me but we just saw it later with
the engines yeah
it's just a beautiful combination so can
you guys see
Quincy a now right
let's not blender our Queens so no
Bishop d4 no Bishop f4 no Queen c8 can
we just ignore the threat of detective
three I don't know can we improve nine
eight seven
I think I can just take now your night
right there's no Queen f6 now it's
extremely beautiful 94 but actually
Knight e4 is the winning move do you see
why not 90 40 take c3 huh forcing moves
Knight f6 Kintex g7 huh no almost
exactly this was a brilliant idea
so 94 wins the game of course White's
threat is to go Bishop h6 followed by
Knight f6 checkmate
but if D takes c3 there is native six
first in black skin to take in g7 and
now d4 and suddenly this queen is coming
287 and it's gonna be checkmate so 94
was a really beautiful combination but
of course I mean even if I have 40
minutes in the clock probably I wouldn't
see it so imagine with 30 seconds after
d4 yes so move I was all the time
calculating route c7 and then trying to
see what happens after Queen d1 stuff
like that but then he suddenly pushes d4
and then you got 30 seconds here and you
just are able to see that Bishop d4 just
looses on the spot because of Queen d5
so I want Bishop f4 here at this point
look still okay right so how would you
play now with black
Queen Bishop d7 okay let's see this is
interesting but how about if I just play
rook c1 now or I could even sorry rook
e8
and then I just go for example 94 you
want to take it I'll take back and this
looks okay for white
I mean grew k-8 you wanna take this guy
here I'm not so sure you are even able
to take it because after Queen takes
rook takes rook c4 there is a pinna
where they're sure you are not
threatening anything in this position or
even Bishop h6 as you say so do you have
a lot of background problems Bishop
eight six actually it's threatened Queen
c8 winning the game on the spot so no
and so what do we play of course our
threat with the white pieces to go
ninety four and then Bishop eight six
another six checkmate right so
maybe let's see some demolition
ruk c7 this is what Jorge played in the
game which is the most natural move so
just bring the rook to the open file
attacking the Queen and now if I go up
will be three then group b7 and then the
threat is to go Bishop c3 so that's why
I went to d1 and here it's an important
moment again and this is where Hawkeye
showed his superclass he's 2700 rating
points with an only move here for black
because now it looks like I have
everything protected right a4 is
protected d3 is protected and my plan is
rather simple
I wanna go 94 as we were saying and then
sonar f6 or Bishop h6 ideas you said you
wanted to go Bishop e7 but then 94 and
we are in the same kind of position that
that we were looking before right yeah
you have to take it and then D takes e4
Bishop c3 yes but then I think I can
always call rook edge to this rule is
doing a fantastic job over here and of
course it's not easy it's not easy
mmm there's a lot of job to do here but
and I'm not even sure ok I think I can
take this guy or I can't no I don't
think so but ok so this is fine for
white at least so something comes out to
your minds after Queen d1
rook egg 7 you want to go Bishop b5 here
that sounds nice
so after 94 you want to go Bishop b5
right and then how about if I just let's
say mm-hmm Bishop eight six we should be
e seventh very interesting you're okay
seven let's let's try to think all
together so root K 7
I didn't think about this move before
okay seven and now so so show show
can we go Queen f3 Wow I just saw a
beautiful line look at look at this line
so Queen here 3 Queen a 4 and then I was
thinking about Queen efore but it's not
possible why Bishop d3 Queen takes c3
Queen a one Kim C 2 and look at this
move boom King a 1 and now Bishop d3
checkmate Wow so this root K 7 is a
fantastic suggestion let's try to think
it's not working for some reason but
because I remembered that the engine was
given another option and it was the only
one but then we have to find a solution
g5 I could be nine eight seven but I'm
not so sure because now you can play
Bishop e5 kg7
not so easy right let's think a little
bit all together root k7 yes yes
yeah now King h8 right but then this
could be even possible
I don't know Queen c1 yeah Quincy one
and if you take no you take on d3 we
gotta be careful here you take on the
three and then white is completely
losing I wanted to go Quincy to another
to go Quincy eight but then I think you
can just go on rook c8 or something like
that right so Ruki seven very very
interesting let's see so let's think
can I go Quincy to maybe ah I could
probably go Quincy to and then if you
play Bishop be five days
Quincy eight king 87 and then 85 or
something like that right so the best
move is not yes tell me
yeah yes
Queeny for ya Queenie for Queen a for
Bishop d3 I just go Queen c2 right and
then White's a piece up after Bishop
takes King takes so yeah
Tom yeah the same position elated wrong
yeah so here there's a better move it's
a crazy move but when I saw it and then
when he played it and then I had 30
seconds again I wanted to cry I wanted
to run no no it's quite okay for for for
white it's actually a zero point zero
zero according to the engine with the
with the mode that he found sorry both
we have like 30 seconds each and here's
a superclass player yeah almost his he
was like he is like number 60 in the
wall or 70 in the world something like
so he found this move boom Bishop b5 and
then you see this move and then you have
to move something in 30 seconds
what do you move first I couldn't
understand anything
yes
you take the b5 bishop and then after
Brooke a7 this is what actually happened
in the game
and black is threatening to go Queen a
to and rook c7 right and then my King
hasn't got a room after King c2 so it
looks like checkmate
so you were thinking about all the moves
instead of taking on b5 yes
now I've realized that that's were I to
be a big right on the pyramid
yes exactly you are right
if we take the bishop after root k7y
it's gonna be or looks like white is in
trouble maybe not I don't know what do
you think will you play something
different from a takes me fine here
I mean black is just taking on a four
and then and then Bishop c2 and then I
have to resign and then if I play b3 or
something like this I think black and
just take on a on a four and then this
looks like completely waiting to for
black queen before his common rugby
sevens etc so what do we play them I
mean to be honest I had just two seconds
in the clock and then I just took the
bishop yeah so I had to do something and
I took the bishop and then after rook a
seven and again I have 30 seconds in the
clock and there's only one move who
saves the game for white here now you
know what's the threat 94 no because
Queen a2 and Roxy 7 and boom
okay sorry Queen b3 Queen b3 then Queen
a1 check King c2 and Brooke c7 and same
problem we have no room for a kin No
I played Queen f3 because I thought his
only chance was to go Queen a to king C
2 rooks e7 and then I wanted to go Queen
g6 and try to hold that maybe I have
some chances I wrote on a piece on a
pawn for the quid mcinnis in a pretty
bad position but okay but there is even
after Queen f3 there is a really
beautiful line that I'm going to show
you but there's one good move here for
white what's the only move that stops
Roxy 7 okay yes we're putting your hand
on c7 yeah knight c6 doesn't work
because of f2 X is six and we're in the
same situation but with a with a piece
down yeah and then we have to find the
same solution but without the neck
yes Queen c2 ok that stops rook c7 but
then this is checkmate in one move quick
a what right
checkmate and then we have to go and
take a shower so so after Luke a7
there's one simple move who stops e7
basics that's a solution b6 because now
if white goes a black horse Queen a one
Kinsey tune there is no check on c7 if
you take it now that's a different story
you take the b61 then you are not
threatening anything right now and then
I have a really important temple to to
put my pieces in up in a better place
right for example Queen b3 and then I
think White's winning let's say you go
back to Queen a5 I got the main goal
Roxy one Queen a one king c2 and then
keen d1 and why these women so no b6
after basics there is only one good move
for black
Ruka eight this is a very good try for
black because you are threatening the
same stuff rook c8 and then you gotta go
b7 and now there's only one good line
for black here to save the game to force
the draw Queen exactly Queen a1 or queen
a2 and queen a4 and then you have to go
for the triple repetition because you go
b3 the screen a - and then after King c1
bishops a3 checkmate so that's why here
this would have been a triple repetition
but instead I thought I could be smart
and play Queen f3
but then this a beautiful line who
finishes the game for black so I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna give you a hint this
skin will end that will end up on b8 and
then after two moves I saw that my King
was gonna end up on ba but then when
somebody finds a beautiful combination
you have to show respect
yeah and then you have to allow your
opponent to checkmate you in a beautiful
way so find a way
yep
yeah yeah great
you saw it okay so this is the line
because I thought okay quick he went
Queen a one King see two rooks he
selling King b3 and I thought okay I'm
winning I'm winning
what is it gonna do I mean it has no
checks Brooks III that kind of work come
on
Brooks III I just take the bishop and
then my team will run away will scape
and then I'm threatening all the time
Queenie for Queen a checkmate but this
is crushing this rooks III can I take
the rook why and then Keaney - so can I
take yes
I mean it's legal it's legal
yeah exactly Quint xe3 Keenan - Quincy -
King a1 and Bishop c3 checkmate so I can
take this rope so what's the only move
keep before and then I want son of you
to give me the whole line I know yes
King a5 yeah Kim b6 huh
not that is he
not that easy right you see a way you
see a way to yes back there yes Kim b6
Kim b6 and then keep checking me yeah so
we are here Queen B - King a5 and now
you said Queen III right Kim b6 there's
only one good check for you now there
what's that check yes exactly
I'm thinking a six
and then Quincy a then I escaped back to
a five you had almost you have me almost
after Quincy file check King a six days
one better move sorry for all the arrows
yeah no it's a mess 27 is not a check
Mikey Nissan a six it's very important
in chess to try to calculate everything
in your mind without moving the pieces
so okay the checkmate is like that wing
a three team b6 Queen c5 King a6 and now
yes perfect Luke a3 King b7 now
checkmate in two moves perfect and then
Kim b8 awesome great you checkmated me
so this is the way the game finished
remember this skin started on a1 was
very happy here
and now it ended up on b8 so you saw
this was a crazy game I had a lot of
opportunities I had this first
opportunity with Bishop 87 then I had a
second chance with this difficult line
with Knight e4 and then he really
impressed me with this most Bishop b5
and then rook c3 so yeah this concludes
this lecture we're going to make a short
break before starting the second lecture
where we're going to see B she announced
lost in the grand Swiss of feather which
is taking place in Isle of Man in Great
Britain okay thank you very much for
coming
[Music]
you
you